JOE CORKERY: Excellent.
All right, hello, everybody.
I'm so excited to see
so many people here
at the end of the day.
And I'm really excited
to be here talking
to you about enterprise
ops, in particular managing
your business on GCP and beyond.
Now I know I am the
last thing between you
and tasty beverages.
So I'm going to
get to the point.
And my hope is that if there's
one thing that you take away
from this presentation is
that we have you covered,
either natively on GCP,
or through our growing
ecosystem of partners, to help
you address your enterprise ops
needs, in particular automation,
governance, risk, compliance.
So this is a high
level agenda of what
I'm going to talk about.
The first half of
the session, I'm
going to be focusing primarily
on what we're doing on GCP.
And then I'm going to turn
it over to our partners
who we announced
today, Splunk and BMC,
and they're going to come
onstage and demonstrate some
of their integrations and
tell you a little bit more
about the applications and
what you can do with them.
So broadly, I'm going to
talk a little bit about some
of the management tools that
are available to you, dive
a little bit into
automation, governance, risk,
and compliance.
And then I'm going to
dive a little bit deeper
into Cloud Audit Logs, which
is a new service that we're
launching and I'm really
quite excited about.
So intuitive intelligent
management-- one
of the great things
about the Cloud Platform
is that you don't have to work
with multiple systems that
don't talk to each other.
You don't have to deal
with multiple vendors,
a wide variety of systems
to provision resources.
If you want to
generate a new VM,
if you want to get
new storage, if you
want to change
your networking, it
can all be done from
within the same place.
You can easily provision
resources with a single click,
and more importantly,
deprovision them.
So you no longer have
to deal with that world
where adding new
resources requires a PO.
It's really just a single click.
We also want to ensure
that you can manage
your environment your way.
And what does that mean?
What we know is that there
are lots of different people
who are managing
these environments
and you have different
preferences for how
you're going to want
to work with this.
Many of you may want to come
to this and work with a web UI
like I demonstrated on the
last page, our Cloud Console.
But many of you
are going to want
to interact with
it through an API
or through the command
line interface.
And so we make sure
that all of our services
expose their capabilities
through a REST API,
through a command line
interface, as well as
that Cloud Console.
Now when problems happen,
and as they always do,
they often happen when you're
not in front of your desktop.
And so to complement or to
help deal with that situation,
we provide a mobile management
and monitoring tool.
So you can download this
mobile Cloud Console
for Android or iOS.
And it allows you to look
and see your environment.
So you can see.
You can do the
network monitoring.
You can look at logs.
If you want to interact
with individual resources,
you can do that as well.
For instance, you can look
and see this VM is causing you
problems, and you can
stop it, delete it.
And if you really want
to connect to it via SSH
on your phone, you
can do that too.
So that was really just
kind of a highlight overview
of some of the management tools
that are available to you.
I'm going to touch briefly
now on automation, governance,
risk, compliance.
And the first area I want
to focus on is automation.
Now you've probably heard a
lot about this in the keynote
this morning, how
Google has really
been very active with
containers for a long time
and have built out great
tools for managing that.
And that has enabled us
to grow our infrastructure
and our workloads much faster
than we've needed to grow
our ops team to support that.
And with that, based
on that experience,
we developed Kubernetes, which
is an open source container
orchestration system.
And we've made it available.
It's governed by an independent
foundation, is enjoying
broad industry support.
Importantly, we're embracing
the concept of multicloud
as well as on-prem
VM bare metal.
So you can use Kubernetes
in all these situations.
And to make it easier for
you, particularly when
working with GCP, we
provide Container Engine,
which is a fully managed
and hosted Kubernetes system
that allows you to very easily
create and deploy clusters
with a single click.
Now I'm not going to talk
too much more about this
because you probably heard
a little bit about it
at the keynote.
But there's also a
great talk tomorrow
at 11:00 AM going into much more
detail about Container Engine.
So I would encourage
you to go to that.
One thing that we know
is that as companies
are moving to the cloud,
you're often either coming
from on-prem or you're in a
multicloud environment, which
means you're already using
tools for IT automation.
And there's a large number
of open source tools
out there that people are using.
And we want you to
be able to continue
to use the tools that you're
comfortable with as you
come to the cloud.
So we encourage our
engineers to participate
in these open source projects
and to contribute to them
to ensure that all these
tools work just as well on GCP
or to ensure that you can
add GCP support to them.
Now governance, this
is going to be quick,
not because it's not
important-- because I
know governance is
really important
and one of our top
feature requests
is around identity
and access management.
But there's a whole talk
tomorrow at 2:15 solely focused
on identity and
access management,
talking about the capabilities
that we have there.
And so I would
really encourage you
to attend that talk as well.
And now lastly in this
section, risk and compliance.
This is an area that
I know is incredibly
important to enterprises
and large organizations.
And every year we participate
in independent audits
of our infrastructure,
our services,
our different operations.
And the goal here is
to be comprehensive
and to provide assurances
of the information security
to help you feel
comfortable with this
and to meet your security
and compliance needs.
So you can see we've met
a number of cloud platform
certifications.
As a result of that, we're also
able to sign business associate
agreements if you're working in
a HIPAA regulated environment.
And then thinking more about
data security and privacy, just
this past December, we launched
EU model contract clauses
to help you with
managing your EU data.
One of the important
things when you're
thinking about
risk and compliance
though is it's great
and very important
that the platform has
these certification
so that you can feel
comfortable with the platform
that you're using.
But it's also really
important for you
to be able to know what
you're doing on the platform,
because that plays a
major role there as well.
And this ties in nicely
to my next topic,
which are Cloud Audit Logs.
So this is a new
service that we're
providing to allow
you to understand
who did what, where, and when
on Google Cloud Platform.
And it's built on the
same proven and scalable
infrastructure that powers
all of our other cloud logging
services.
And what's nice about this
is that the events that
are captured in these logs,
they're available to you
in the Cloud Console, as was
demonstrated in the keynote
this morning, as well
alongside all the other logs
in Stackdriver, which
you probably saw as well.
And this requires no
configuration on your part.
They're just there.
They're available to you.
And this has actually
been really embraced
by a lot of our early customers
who have been using this.
This quote from
Snapchat, from Subhash,
who says, "Snapchat handles
sensitive user data,
and it trusts Google Cloud
Platform with its storage.
Cloud Audit Logging
provides us the ability
to monitor this data across
a variety of resource
types in near real
time, and for our teams
to take timely
action if needed."
So that's meeting our goals.
This is what we want
you to be able to do.
So I want to talk a little
bit more about the audit
logs themselves, because this
is important to understand.
There are actually two
different type of Audit logs.
The first one is the
Admin Activity log.
And this captures every
user action or API method
that modifies the
configuration or metadata
of a service or a project.
So for instance when
you set the IAM policy,
if you create a new project,
if you deploy a new App Engine
application, all of
those get captured here.
Those are actions that you're
taking that make a change
to the service of the project.
And these are always
on, for every project,
no work required on your part.
They're just available.
And this is true
for all the services
that have completed their
integration with the App Engine
infrastructure-- the Audit
Logging infrastructure.
And I say there
are no exemptions,
and that means
basically everything
that you do, all of
these actions get logged.
Now the Data Access log
is a little bit different.
This is where we capture
all of your interactions,
whether they're
modifications or just
reads, with user provided data
that's managed by the service.
So as an example of
this, with BigQuery,
when you import data
to a table a BigQuery,
or if you export
data from BigQuery,
or if you do a query within
BigQuery, all of these
get captured in the
data access log.
And we've broken them out
into two different logs
because they have
different use cases.
And also the Data
Access log tends
to be a lot higher volume
than the Admin Activity log.
So we don't want there to be
one to flood the other out.
I would say the model for
these are mostly opt in.
For the Data Access
logs, you would
have to explicitly turn it on.
Although right now the
BigQuery audit logs
are on by default for
everybody because there's
been such positive
feedback about the value
that they have in understanding
your utilization of BigQuery.
And there's one last point here.
So I had said with
the Admin Activity
logs there were no exemptions.
But with the Data
Access logs, we
do have the capability for
you to exempt certain service
accounts from data
access logging.
Now this isn't a self-serve
process at the moment.
But the idea here
is that you really
want to understand when your
users are looking at data,
not necessarily when
your high QPS application
is querying the data.
So if you have a known,
trusted application running
as a service account,
you can tell us that
and we will exempt
that from logging.
As I said going
back to governance
as we were
introducing IAM, there
are a number of access roles
that are relevant here.
There's the Logs
Reader role which
grants you access to
the Admin Activity logs.
There's the Private
Logs Reader role.
And this is a
separate permission
that grants you access to the
Data Access logs independent
of the Admin Activity logs.
And we do this because
the Data Access
logs contains information
about your access
to user provided data.
So often there's a different
level of sensitivity about
who gets to see those logs.
There's also a
Config Writer role
which allows you to change or
configure the export settings
with the logging system
in that you may not
want to have the person who
is interacting with those logs
also being able to change that.
And then lastly there's
this Logs Writer role
which I put up here
because it's actually not
relevant to Audit logs,
because Audit logs are
special with respect to
the other type of logs
that we collect in
that they're immutable
and nobody can write to them
except for Google services.
So App Engine can
write to these,
but you as a user can't call
the logging API an put logs
into the Audit log streams.
So where do we stand right now?
This is where we are
with Admin Activity logs.
We have a number of
services in beta.
They'll be launching to GA soon.
And we have a large number
of other services coming soon
in the next couple months.
And they're coming soon means
they're either in private alpha
with a number of our early users
or will be to be so shortly.
Data Access logs,
BigQuery is already
providing Data Access
logs for everybody.
If you haven't seen
them, they're there.
And Cloud SQL and Cloud
Storage will be following soon.
So now I'm going to change gears
and do a quick demonstration--
let me just log in-- to show
you the Audit logs in action.
So what you can
see here is, as was
demonstrated earlier
in the keynote today,
is the activity stream.
And you can see the
different interactions
that have happened
inside this project.
So if you look down
here at the bottom,
you can see I
created this project.
I created an application
within the project,
get some of the details there.
I set the IAM policy and
you can see how I set that.
And you can scroll
further up and see we
created create some data
sets, the whole table,
the whole data in BigQuery.
And so there's a wide variety of
interactions that you can see.
What's nice about
the activity stream
is you can also look at
data from multiple projects
simultaneously.
So I have another project here.
And you can see, we were very
active with IAM earlier today.
But you can see that you've
got the Audit log demo here,
enterprise ops demo.
You can see them in between.
You interleave together
relatively easily.
Now one thing that you
could not do prior to today
was look at your Data Access
logs inside the activity
stream.
You can now do that.
So I'm going to click
on Data Access Logs.
And you can now see all my
Data Access log activity here.
So I can look at the
queries I was making.
But what's nice is actually
you scroll down here
and you see these ones with
the exclamation point there.
And that tell you that this
is actually a failed action.
So not only do we capture all
the successful API actions,
we capture all the failures.
And we'll capture it if it
failed because it didn't work.
But we'll also capture it
because you were denied access.
And this is an example
where my colleagues here, we
pulled in this HR database.
And he was trying
to join the employee
IDs with the compensation.
And he didn't have access to
the compensation database.
And so he was denied
that and was not
able to see those there.
And now I want to talk
quickly about the fact
that, as we said earlier, the
Audit logs are available to you
in activity stream.
But we also have this nice tight
integration with Stackdriver.
So you can look at all of your
logs inside the Stackdriver
logs viewer just like
you could anywhere else.
And you can see the
different resources.
You can see the
different log types.
You can expand the nicely
structured logs here.
And I've actually filter this
by using this the text filters.
So I was looking for all the job
service dot insert operations.
But I could also
filter this by, I
if want to see,
what did I do, where
are the actions
that I performed,
I can filter those
there as well.
By virtue of this
integration, you
can also take advantage of
the export capabilities.
So I can export these logs for
long term archival and storage
to Cloud Storage.
I can also export them to
BigQuery which is actually
very valuable
because it gives you
additional types of insight.
And I'm going to show
you that right here.
So I'm actually going
use BigQuery to look
at the BigQuery Audit logs.
Because what you can do now
is you can gain more insight
and get kind of a rough
estimate of your utilization
and how that translates
into your spend.
So we created this query here,
seven day spend, run the query.
And it just takes a second
to operate over that.
And it sees that over
the past five days,
it looks like I have
spent $0.05 on BigQuery.
So go me for not
spending a lot of money.
But I just didn't have a lot
of time to play with this.
But what's nice about
this is that because these
are the Audit logs, we're
also capturing the information
around who's doing this.
So if I want to
find out-- so yes,
we found out that $0.05
was spent on this.
I can instead run
this by query by user.
And it'll break
it out and you can
see that my work account
was responsible for $0.04.
I used my personal account as
another way in to check it out.
And that was worth $0.01.
And my colleague
Omer, he actually
didn't rack up any money
because he kept getting denied.
And so you can see that it's
just a great use of BigQuery
to look at BigQuery's own logs.
And now if I go back
to the logs viewer,
we can actually see these
are the fresh entries that I
was just-- oh, those
are different ones.
So if I go back to the
top service dot insert,
and you can see that these
were the logs that I just
triggered a moment ago.
And then so just coming
quickly back to exports,
the one export I
didn't touch on already
was our ability to
export to Pub/Sub.
And this gives you the ability
to publish your logs to Pub/Sub
where anybody listening to
those you've granted access to
can then do further
processing on the logs.
So if you want to have
Dataflow jobs listening to that
and processing your
logs, you can do that.
But it also means we can partner
with a variety of third parties
who can also listen on these.
And that way it allows
you to push your logs
to a variety of our partners.
Can we switch back to my slides?
Thank you.
So as you may have
heard, we're announcing
a number of partnerships today.
In particular Slunk and Tenable
we've partnered with to send
logs out of Stackdriver
logging to their systems.
Logentries was a
partner before hand.
And at this point I'd like to
invite Mark Chene from Splunk
to come up on stage and
tell us a little bit more
about Splunk, the partnership,
and what you can do.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MARK CHENE: So good
evening everyone.
My name is Mark Chene.
I'm a product manager for the
IT markets team at Splunk.
And today, number one,
is to make sure they all
know who Splunk is.
Number two, if
you're using Splunk
and you're deploying
on GCP, I want
to demonstrate
the value that you
can get by securing
and monitoring
your services with Splunk.
And three of course,
everybody wants to see a demo,
so I'll show you the
demo of integrating
Splunk ingesting
some of the logs
that Joe just talked about.
So Splunk comes from the
word spelunking, which means
exploring underground caves.
These caves can often be
viewed as all these sources
of information, machine data,
that often go unexplored.
Unless of course there's
a mission critical problem
with your services
or insecurity,
and all of a sudden you get
all of these stakeholders,
your app architects, your
developers, your security guys
all wanting today's
logs, yesterday's logs,
and all the logs to be
able to better troubleshoot
the problem.
So our mission at
Splunk is simple.
We want to make machine
data accessible, usable,
and valuable to everyone.
Let me walk you through
our product portfolio
to get a better understanding
of what Splunk is.
Splunk is a platform for
operational intelligence.
So this means that we can
search, analyze, monitor,
and visualize any
unstructured data.
We're more than just logs.
We can mobile
performance metrics.
We can monitor stream data and
any other type of machine data,
even oil rig data.
And the great thing
is we offer this
on-premise or in the cloud.
Whether you're just
getting started
with 10 gigabytes
of data per day
or you need to grow to several
petabytes of data per day,
as some of our largest
customers use Splunk for today,
this is something we can
accommodate your needs.
And most importantly, who
has a Hunk in their product?
What a great game.
I'm sure Eric would
love that name.
Hunk is our Splunk
analytics for Hadoop.
So if you have all
these data lakes
and you don't want to,
obviously, change that data,
you just want to be able to
search and analyze that data,
we can also help you with that.
We have a rich ecosystem
of applications
and add on that can
collect information
from all these technologies
to help you analyze
some of that information.
These are built by our partners,
our customers, and ourselves.
There's over a thousand of them
in our app store, our store
for all of our Splunkbase.
Last, we also offer
premium solution
but are prebuilt for
very specific use case
to help your IT operations
and security teams address
very specific needs.
We're not a startup anymore.
We've been around
for over 10 years.
And we have 11,000
customers where
we've proven the
value of Splunk,
of using Splunk to be able to
Splunk all this machine data.
If you're not on this list yet,
I'd love to work with you guys
and make sure that
you get on this list.
So I'm excited to
stand in front of you
to announce our Splunk add-on
for Google Cloud Platform.
It's free on Splunkbase.
You can download it today.
It'll help you subscribe
to any Pub/Sub events
that you have in GCP.
You can securely access
that information,
which includes all
of the logs exports
that you can define by
service and by source,
as Joe just talked about.
Furthermore, we've
also added the ability
to subscribe to your
Stackdriver monitoring API.
So this will give you
access to all the streaming
performance metrics, whether
its CPU utilization, memory
utilization, disk I/O for
your Cloud SQL services,
for your BigQuery, Compute
Engine, Container Engine,
into Splunk to unify all that
data in one central location.
So the partnership
between Splunk and GCP
was critical for
our success in order
to empower our customers,
you, to get that real time IT
and business insight in
securing the reliability
of your services.
So without further delay,
let me show you a demo.
And you may have to log me in.
Oh, perfect.
Advance.
All right, cool.
All right, so we're going to
talk about a very specific
scenario here.
So this is a scenario for Paul.
He's a level three
support analyst.
And he was just about to go for
happy hour or whatever, 5:50,
but he needs to stay
here because he just got
a critical problem
that he needs to solve.
And how he's going to do
this is by using Splunk.
And our foundation for Splunk
is our searching capability.
Everything starts with a search.
And we automatically
index content
by host, source,
source type, and time.
It's easy for them
to go and collect,
analyze all of this information
centrally from our search
interface.
Very comprehensive search
processing language
that allows you to
create statistics, apply
any arithmetic operators
and several functions
to be able to summarize and
analyze some of that data.
So in this case we're
looking at JSON objects.
But any type of
unstructured data
we automatically create fields
and categories of information
that's automatically visualized
and analyzed by the payloads
that we're looking at.
So in this case
here, you can see
all of the information we've
been able to quickly filter
by specific log type.
And you can also create
quick visualizations
from these logs that
are being collected.
So here Paul wants to be able
to see how this data is changing
over time.
So I'll create a
top end chart to be
able to see how my data's doing.
So here I see a
change by resource
that has been changed
using some of the activity
logs that I'm looking at.
And I can change
all kinds of-- apply
all kinds of rich
visualization to this data.
I can send that to a report.
I can create a new dashboard.
Or in this case here,
I'll go ahead and add it
to an existing dashboard.
So this is an example
dashboard that
summarizes all of my GCP
log events that I have.
All the data can be viewed
by service, by source.
And I can quickly drill in
by specific areas of interest
or how things are
trending over time.
All this information
is coming from GCP.
On top of that,
Paul also has access
to machine learning capability.
I can go ahead and take, as
an example, my Stackdriver
cloud monitoring metrics
and go and understand
some of the numeric outliers.
Whether I'm trying to predict
problems, understand outliers,
or forecasting
problems, these are
all things that are built
in natively in the platform.
Paul also has access to IT
Service Intelligence, which
is an IT operation
tool that gives you
a service aware view
of all of the services
that Paul is
responsible to monitor.
All the KPIs are all
powered by the searches
that we just talked about.
In here Paul can see
which KPIs are impacted,
the Splunkdepo.com, in this
case this ecommerce site, which
one is impacted.
He also has access to
the ITSI glass tables.
Who has a Visio diagram
in their environment
that represents their
ecosystem, or some kind
of a scribble on a
whiteboard that you
want to be able to use
and be able to put KPIs
on top of that?
That's what glass
table allows you to do.
All these services that you
have, you can pull these KPIs.
And the great thing is you
can drill into these KPIs
to get more detailed
analysis on the KPIs
that are impacting the services.
I can move these swim lanes.
This is called the
ITSI deep dive.
This is where Paul in this case,
a level three support analyst,
may spend a lot of time trying
to triage what's going on
in his environment and
when the problem happened,
and what's that leading
indicator that may have caused
the problem in my environment.
IT Service Intelligence
also comes with modules.
These modules is
just a normalization
of well known technologies-- as
an example operating systems,
load balancers, and others--
where it normalizes the data
and provides more
drill down capability
into specific diagnostics
views to help you more triage
problems.
In this case here we're
seeing a degradation
in some of the network.
I know we always want to be
able to blame the network,
but in this case you want to go
do a little bit more assessment
to find out why we're seeing
a degradation in the network
utilization.
One of the questions
that Paul always
asks himself is what
changed in my environment?
By ingesting the
GCP activity logs,
I know exactly which changed.
And I'm seeing that
there's a trend here
that's abnormal or different
than what I've previously seen.
But drilling into these
dashboards that I have,
I'm able to go and understand
what changed, who changed it,
and when did it change.
So in this case here,
without even a need
to create a war room and
engage my DBA, my network guy,
I can go and talk
to this one person
that likely did a change that
was during unplanned work
hours.
You don't go do changes
during a peak workload.
So in this case I have all
our access to the raw data,
any visualizations that
we offer in Splunk.
You can drill down to the actual
payload, the unstructured data
to further analyze it.
And in this case Paul can
just pick up the phone,
call Mark and find
out why he did
those changes to the firewall.
As a call to action,
love you guys,
if you're not using
Splunk today, it's free.
It's available on our website
where you can get from a SaaS.
You can download it or use
it in a cloud environment
or download it on-premise.
We're at booth 39 if you
have any other question.
And if you're not using
the GCP add-on yet,
it just launched today.
Please go ahead
and give it a try.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
JOE CORKERY: Thanks
so much Mark.
I'm really excited
about that integration.
Now I'd like to introduce
everybody to a Atanu Neogi
and Nitin Navare from
BMC who are going
to tell you a little
bit more about BMC
and the integrations with GCP.
Come on up.
NITIN NAVARE: Thanks Joe.
Hi, I'm Nitin Navare.
ATANU NEOGI: Atanu Neogi.
We'll very briefly
in the remaining term
have a little talk
about BMC software
and its collaboration with
Google in the context of Google
Compute Cloud to give you
enterprise cloud offering
that's hybrid, heterogeneous,
secure, trusted, governed,
and monitored
So if you typically think of
your application life cycle,
this is the general
loop around it.
And you have the design stage
of building applications
and deploy them.
And then subsequently
you scale both
for performance and
analytics purposes
as well as you monitor
for compliance, security,
and patch.
In this particular
picture, heterogeneity
become a recurrent them, right?
You want to design it for
single Compute instances,
for multitier applications that
grows infrastructure, platform,
database, containers.
And then you want to deploy
whatever way you want.
You want to deploy it
either on-premise data
center, in Google Compute,
in Google App Engines.
You want to deploy it other
public cloud offerings.
And subsequently you want
to be able to monitor
them, scale them
as necessary based
on your predefined policies.
You want to check for
compliance failures.
security intrusions,
and subsequently remediate
those failures and intrusions
and scale accordingly
based on monitoring data.
So for governance
and trust, you have
the mandatory requirements,
the industry compliance
regulations, the PCI, HIPAA.
and all the standard ones.
But also every
single organization
is different, right, and
they have their organization
specific compliance policies.
And some of those compliance
policies are automated.
And some of those
compliance policies
you build based on the data
that you have available.
And applying those compliance
policies, finding the failures,
and remediating them
in a manner that's
fully governed by
your policies itself
is a significant requirement
for all enterprises.
So in this Google-BMC
collaborative partnership,
we have you covered.
As Joe started with the
presentation, the Google Cloud
Platform and BMC, you can design
your application workload.
You can deploy them in
a heterogeneous manner.
You can scale
them, monitor them.
And you could perform all
aspects of compliance,
security, and patch.
For the hybrid cloud
and compliance, SecOps,
and patch side, BMC offers
Cloud Lifecycle Management,
which provides full hybrid cloud
solution across all stacks.
And subsequently
your workloads can
be further scanned for
compliance failures
and security intrusions
and patch issues,
and remediate it using these
server automation and network
automation solutions.
For the analytics part,
I hand it over to Nitin.
NITIN NAVARE: So on
the monitoring front,
the slides are highlighting
a couple of BMC products
which are delivered via SaaS.
They are basically TrueSight
Pulse and TrueSight Analytics.
There are more
products which are
available on the monitoring
from that you guys can check out
on the BMC side.
Pulse basically focuses on
infrastructure monitoring.
And the key value
proposition there is--
and I'll be demoing it later--
is the one second resolution.
And you'd be able to see that.
On the TrueSight
Analytics front,
it is focusing on IT
operation analytics.
You can combine your business
and infrastructure data
sources.
The data can come from anywhere.
It doesn't have to
be a BMC product.
And that product is going
to be released in April.
TrueSight Pulse is
available right now.
ATANU NEOGI: So this
particular picture
depicts in a kind of minimized
way or a minimalistic way
the entire ecosystem
of BMC solutions,
focusing on the
enterprise ops aspects.
So the BMC Cloud
Lifecycle Management
lets your design
and deploy, as we'll
demonstrate a little
later, hybrid cloud
solutions across
workloads distributed
across the stack of
different types of offerings
and different types of cloud.
Subsequently, you can have
full scale server and network
automations based on the design,
deploy, monitor, remediate
policies.
And they offer industry
leading compliance, patch,
and SecOps solutions.
And as Nitin talked
about, you can then
subscribe to the
various monitoring
and analytics applications.
All of these BMC
solutions are connected
to the flagship Change
Management, ITSM, and CMDB
solutions from BMC.
So with that, we'll switch
over to the first part
of our demo, which is the
hybrid cloud management.
NITIN NAVARE: No, it's
still the same laptop.
Next slide.
MALE SPEAKER: Just
go to the next slide.
ATANU NEOGI: OK.
All right, so this is BMC Cloud
Lifecycle Management solution.
What we're seeing
here is a building
of our service blueprint.
The blueprint lets you design
your cloud offering once,
and subsequently deploy
it wherever you want,
in a policy driven manner.
And those policies
can be plugged
into two different types
of automation schemes,
including capacity driven
placement, charge driven
placement, [INAUDIBLE]
driven placement.
So here we're typically
walking on a LAMP stack,
which is to be deployed on one
single particular VM instance.
That VM instance is mapped
onto an installable resources
or a particular image, which
will show that it is pointing
to a Google Cloud image.
And once this
particular blueprint
is decided to be deployed,
the deployment is driven
and the last mileage
decisions are made entirely
by the policies we have set up.
And it could be deployed
in Google Compute cloud.
It could be deployed in any
of the infrastructure stack
you have chosen for you
on-premise environment
or any of the other
public cloud offerings.
Here in this demo
we'll show that once
this blueprint is deployed to
the Google Compute cloud, how
subsequently that
information is absorbed
in a normalized seamless manner
in Cloud Lifecycle Management.
And further, the compliance
and patch actions
are done in an automated manner.
So the blueprint designers
have a grammar that's embedded
and that's manageable
through APIs
and has a version control
scheme that's composable.
So it's a full scale SGDC.
And then we'll show that
that particular blueprint
was pointing to this image
in Google Compute cloud.
And once this blueprint was
provisioned or deployed,
it led to a Google
Compute instance
that will be further
checked immediately
for compliance failures.
And you see that the
installable resource which is
highlighted, which is the
pointer to the Google Compute
instance.
However, it can be pointed
to any particular types of VM
images or content or images
or other types of stack
that you want your
workloads to run on.
The blueprint images--
the blueprint grammar
is fully public and
controlled through rest APIs.
And they can be
used as documents.
Looking into the Google
Compute instances--
so this is the footprint
in the Google Cloud.
And we see that this
is a running instance
with one single public IP.
You can have multiple
IPs based on the policies
that you have set
up for blueprint.
And this is the BMC Cloud
Lifecycle Management
where that particle VM appears.
And in a manner that's kind
of seamless and transparent,
the consumers of
your cloud doesn't
need to know where exactly
the workload is running.
And all the full
lifecycle management
of this particular
workload can be powered
from this single pane of glass.
And BMC offers a
set of APIs by which
your cloud offerings across
all the different multiple
hybrid clouds can be managed
using single type of APIs.
With that, we'll move onto
the next part of the demo
where the Cloud Lifecycle
Management solution, where
the VM was deployed
can be used to check
for compliance failures.
So this is the server
automation suite,
which does compliance checks.
So in this case we see that
for this particular server,
there was an automated
compliance run
for our particular CVE, which
had led to this compliance
failure.
And that compliance
failure was detected
the moment the compliance
run was performed.
And then it was
automatically remediated
based on the policy
that you have set up
for your public cloud offerings.
And that remediation job
completed successfully.
Subsequent to that,
another compliance run
was made to ensure that
this compliance remediation
laws completed successfully
and it did resolve
the problem that had triggered
compliance failure to begin
with.
This policy or this mechanism
is applicable not only
to custom compliance
policies but all types all
industry standards
like HIPPA, SOX.
And they come out of
the box, the support
for all the industry
standard compliances.
For custom compliances, you
can build custom compliance
policies for CVEs and
beyond, and any other kind
of particular
problems or intrusions
you are concerned about in
your public cloud offerings.
And they apply seamlessly
and transparently across all
of your offerings
in public cloud,
in all different
types of public cloud,
as well as enterprise
data centers.
With that, sure.
So switch over to the--
NITIN NAVARE: Can you
switch over to my laptop?
OK.
So what I'm going
to demonstrate here
is how you can use BMC
TrueSight Pulse to monitor
a VM which has been deployed
on the Google Cloud platform.
The demo is going to
focus on the VM which
is applied on Google
Cloud, but Pulse
can be used for monitoring
your VMs or any infrastructure
anywhere on-prem or cloud.
So what you have here is a
BMC TrueSight Pulse dashboard.
In terms of the
setup, what we have is
BMC Google demo3 is a VM
which has been deployed.
It has been deployed
using the CLM blueprint.
And it has been deployed
with the Pulse meter, which
is essentially an agent
which sits on the VM.
And that is an nGenx server,
which is also being monitored.
We also have a
custom plug-in which
monitors the number
of connections
from a single client.
And that's going to be
important for us for the demo.
So as you can see
here, the dashboard
is being updated in real time.
You'll be tracking the nGenx
connection handled, CPU,
inbound network traffic, and
the single client connections.
Now Joe here is fiddling
with his phone looking board.
But what he's
going to do is he's
going to trigger a denial of
service attack as we speak.
The dashboard will
update fairly quickly,
and you will start seeing
a spike in the nGenx
connections handled.
This is a live demo,
so hopefully everything
is working fine in terms
of the network connection.
And you should start
seeing the spike.
So as you can see
here, the number
of connections handled by the
nGenx server has spiked up.
You can also see the
alarm bell turning red,
essentially indicating that
an alarm was triggered.
You can also see that
the connections have been
initiated from a single line.
I also just received
an email which
basically shows that the
number of connections
have been exceeded.
And basically we had a
threshold set for this purpose.
Now if you see over
here, I can also,
because of the custom
plug-in, I can find out
where the connections
are being initiated from.
So essentially it is this
IP address, 104.197.208.103.
4/1/87 The demo
script is triggered
or is supposed to run
for around 20 seconds.
Yeah, so now things
about back to normal.
The alarm condition
has disappeared.
And I also got another email
indicating that the problem has
been resolved.
With that, I'm going
to hand it over to Joe.
JOE CORKERY: Thank
you very much guys.
Let's all--
NITIN NAVARE: Switch back
to the slides please.
[APPLAUSE]
JOE CORKERY: Those were just
our backup slides in case
we weren't able to do it live.
So first of all, thank you
everyone for still being here.
I know happy hour
starts the moment
we walk out of this room.
I'm very excited about that.
And so one of the
things you might
be asking, well, in the theme of
this conference, what is next?
Well happy hour's next.
But tomorrow, you should go
to the container management
talk about Google Container
Engine and Kubernetes
at 11 o'clock.
There's also a talk at 2:30 on
identity and access management.
And I would strongly encourage
you to visit our partners
in their booths.
Plus Splunk and BMC
have booths out there
and they can show you
this more in detail.
I know they'd be
happy to talk to you.
We're really excited
about these partnerships.
And like I said earlier,
we have this theme,
we've got you covered.
We're either going
to do it ourselves
or we're going to work
with great partners
to help provide the
functionality that you need.
And with that,
thank you very much.